all right well let's move on to
headlines number one i want to start
with this very instructive case here
this was reported on the daily wires as
a male student at embry riddle
aeronautical university
is suing after the school expelled him
for sexual misconduct
even after evidence was presented that
showed he was the victim the student
referred to as john doe in court
documents
um says in his lawsuit that he informed
er a u that he was too intoxicated to
engage in sexual activity
and witness statements back him up yet
the school relied on antiquated gender
stereotypes about male sexuality
decided to say his claim wasn't credible
so
um that's the that's the the
introduction to the case this is here
are some of the specifics
jane and john doe no relation let's hope
um
girl and guy on this college campus i
suspect that's not the real names
they've been texting for weeks they meet
up at a party i think
john is 15 drinks in okay completely
hammered
they go back to uh i think it was
his place and they
you know have they have
sexual relations she initiates
sexual contact with this extremely drunk
man then she spends the night
the next morning she leaves later on she
decides that she was raped
even though she never said during the
sexual activity that she wanted to stop
or that she didn't consent never said
that
she was a willing participant the entire
time and again she was the initiator
actually
of this sexual activity the school
expels
john so now he's suing and i hope that
he bankrupts the school and takes every
dime that it has
um the standard of consent on college
campuses is that drunk people
cannot consent and a great many men have
been expelled or worse for having sex
with drunk women
now here we have a woman having sex with
a drunk man
and witnesses say by the way that she
she seemed fine and sober he was the one
that was
uh you know completely gone
so by this standard she is the rapist
she should have been expelled he's the
victim
yet he gets the penalty now
in reality of course nobody is the
victim here well he is the victim now
he's a victim in a very serious way a
victim of a false rape claim getting
expelled for no reason
so he really is a victim but in terms of
the sexual encounter itself
nobody's a victim when two people get
together and willingly engage in sexual
activity with one another
there is no rape that's not rape if you
had one too many
drinks or or several too many drinks
that doesn't make it rape either because
if it did
then the vast majority of all sexual
contact
on college campuses is rape
and often both participants are raping
each other
but the whole notion is just nonsensical
and sick
and wrong but again that's the standard
established
them's the rules yes we could easily say
that john also was a willing participant
he never said no he never tried to leave
i by by any same
definition of the term that's certain
that's not rape again
both if you have two willing
participants in a sexual act
it's not rape a rape by definition is
when one participant is not willing and
is forced to
that's that's rape um
but that's that's all that's that's
normal saying
rational standards that's not the
standard you have on college campuses
and by their standard jane should be
expelled not john
now eve introducing rational insane
standards
she should be expelled now at least for
making the false rape claim
uh but even by she should be expelled
two times over actually
what we see at work here is actually as
as the article uh
references it's actually kind of an
antiquated chivalrous notion
where the man is more responsible in a
sexual act than the woman is
and it's the man's job to protect the
woman
from herself that's the way these issues
are handled on college campuses
the man is responsible for a sexual act
that the woman later regrets
even if he was the drunk one and even if
she was the initiator
and even if she was entirely willful the
whole time
which is to say that the woman is what
incompetent
helpless not responsible for her own
actions
that's the message being sent here it's
a very paternalistic
one might even say patriarchal message
of a woman not being responsible for her
own actions and the man being penalized
for not protecting her from her own self
feminists should be up in arms about
this but of course they're not
number two here's the headline from pink
news
uk's biggest cervical cancer charity
shuts down
disgustingly transphobic lie that only
females get cervical cancer
yes they're transphobic lie but by the
way in case you didn't know
dear dear audience only a female has a
cervix
so yes only females can get cervical
cancer
typically the way this works and i'm not
a doctor i admit
but my understanding anyway is that you
you can only get
cancer of a body part
that you you know actually have
so that's one of the reasons why funnily
enough i've never suffered a damage to
my wing
or a ruptured gill plate
you know because i don't have those
things i've also never had canine
distemper or feline leukemia
it's pretty amazing the other day i went
to the doctor for a physical and he came
back and told me that
thank god my elephant tusks are not
infected
and i was pretty relieved by that and
then he explained that the reason
they're not affected because actually i
don't have
any so that that that was pretty great
but remember
this is the pro-science side okay the
side that holds the most
anti-science position the modern world
has ever seen
this is worse even than flat eartherism
a lot of times we
uh criticize anti-science or
pseudoscience positions by saying this
is like saying the earth is flat
this is worse than saying the earth is
flat this is actually a lot worse
but this is the pro-science side
remember that it's important pro science
number three um i never thought i'd
actually say this but terry crews for
president
i i actually think the president from
idiocracy should be the real president
i unironically cruz of course has been
in the news recently uh pushing back
against the false narratives
from blm which here is an example of
courage in the face of the cancel mob
okay this is a man for a man in his
position a black man
to take that stance publicly
okay that takes guts especially as a guy
who you know he makes his living doing
things on mainstream media he's
like the host of america's got talent um
or he was anyway we'll see how that goes
he works for mainstream media companies
they aren't going to like what he's
saying he is probably going to suffer
financially for this
but he sticks to it anyway and that and
that's exactly what needs to happen that
takes courage he deserves a lot of
credit for that
here's the latest from him um he says
a tweet from him where he says defund
pornhub and then tags fight the new drug
so he's going after pornhub now now you
know me
he won my vote right there i was just
hands down that's my vote
but but this is what i really love about
it he goes from
publicly defending one of the most
unpopular opinions you can possibly take
these days
goes from that to taking taking an even
more unpopular position
so he's he's saying to the cancel mob oh
you didn't like what i said over that
get a lo get a load of this over here
you're really you're really not going to
like this
it's almost like he's doing it on
purpose as a middle finger to the
outrage mob
and i love that because that's exactly
what we need to do
president terry cruz let's make it
happen number four a little bit of good
news to come out of this pandemic
no fans are going to be allowed at
eagles or philly's home games apparently
that's the latest
news out of that um now i'm not in favor
of the lockdowns and i really don't see
why we have to keep fans out of the
stadiums why can't you fill them to 30
or 40 capacity or whatever it is um
but i am in favor of banning all philly
sports fans
from all venues and all places
everywhere permanently that i can
endorse
you know for public health and all of
that number five
world of beer in hartford connecticut
has pulled uh pulled from its uh
collection
in an expensive bottle of beer
because customers were complaining about
it the beer was made apparently
to raise awareness and fight racism it's
an anti-racism beer
and it was served to a black customer uh
who recently who i suppose was meant to
be impressed and appreciate the
anti-racism-ness of the beer
but something was lost in translation
because well here's here's the here's
the beer take a look at
that's what the beer that's what the
beer looks like right there
it's a it's a beer dressed up in clan
robes
that's what they did now in fairness it
does say yellow the name of the beer is
yellow belly
which is an insult so i guess you could
say they're calling the clan yellow
bellies
now it's an insult nobody has used since
1875 but still
yet it it you know for somehow
shockingly uh
that didn't exactly resonate and this
brings to mind an old adage which you
know is go
go woke go broke um or maybe it's get
woke go broke or go woke get broke
anyway
woken broke is the idea they tried to be
woke but they accidentally ended up
promoting the clan
which it's it can happen to anyone
that's uh it happens
but that's why it's better to just make
your beer as
just make your beer a beer beer should
just be beer
don't worry about making your beer
socially conscious in fact personally i
prefer for my beer to be totally
unconscious
having a conscious beer freaks me out so
that's the way i would handle that
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description